okay so today's video is gonna center
around type 1 versus type 2 diabetes and
understanding the difference between the
two so let's get started so let's look
at the normal insulin production first
you may know that cells need fuel in
order to perform their cellular
functions and that fuel comes in the
form of a sugar molecule called glucose
so after a meal our meal is digested and
the glucose is absorbed into the
bloodstream so after a meal our blood
sugar our glucose levels rise
now if you notice some of the glucose
are trying to gain entrance into the
cells but they keep getting blocked by
those closed blue doorways those glucose
channels are closed so the pancreas will
respond to high blood sugar by releasing
insulin and what insulin is gonna do
insulin is gonna cause those blue
glucose channels to open so what happens
is the insulin will bind to those black
insulin receptors and once that happens
a series of reactions will occur that
ultimately caused the glucose channels
to open and now that the channels are
open the glucose can enter the cells so
now that the glucose channels are open
the glucose molecules can simply diffuse
into the cells from a high concentration
to a low concentration so as time passes
more and more and more glucose diffuses
into the cells that means that there's
less and less and less glucose in the
actual blood the blood sugar is lowering
and coming back down to normal and this
process continues until as you see in
the animation the cells have received
their fuel so now let's look at type one
diabetes the problem type one diabetics
face is that their pancreas does not
produce enough insulin and so we think
the cause of this is an inheritable
genetic disorder where the immune system
has destroyed the insulin-producing
cells found inside the pancreas these
are called beta cells and once the beta
cells have been destroyed and damaged
they're not able to produce insulin so
the treatment is to inject insulin
whether you use an insulin pump like you
see in the picture where over the course
of the day
insulin is gradually released into the
person's blood or in my animation
whether you flat out inject yourself
directly with insulin now that there
there is insulin in the bloodstream the
insulin can bind to the insulin
receptors which causes the glucose
channels to open and now the glucose can
diffuse into the cells thus lowering the
blood sugar back to normal type 1
diabetes is usually what's referred to
as an early onset disorder because it
develops earlier in the person's life
typically around the age of 20 or so
well let's look at type 2 diabetes now
so for type 2 diabetes you know one of
the problems may be that the person's
pancreas does not produce enough insulin
but for most people who are type 2
diabetics the problem they face is that
the insulin receptors are desensitized
due to a buildup of fat in my animation
look at I just added fat buildup around
the insulin receptors so when they do
produce insulin many people who have our
type 2 diabetics still produce insulin
and they can produce the normal amount
of insulin it's just the insulin cannot
bind to the insulin receptors and so an
inactive lifestyle obesity poor dietary
habits is generally the cause of most
individuals who suffer from type 2
diabetes so if an inactive lifestyle is
one of the leading causes of type 2
diabetes than a change in lifestyle a
shift toward a more fit lifestyle is a
proper form of treatment another form of
treatment is the use of medication
watching my animation the medication is
designed to kind of break apart and
dissolve and break up those
deposits that are around the insulin
receptors this way whether the person's
produce an insulin naturally on their
own or whether they have to inject
themselves with insulin the insulin can
now properly bind to the receptors which
allows the glucose channels to one by
one open now that the glucose channels
are open the high concentration of
glucose in the blood can diffuse into
the cells bringing the blood sugar back
down to a normal level type-2 diabetes
is often called on late onset disorder
because symptoms gradually appear later
on in life
now even though it says after the age of
30 keep in mind that there are warning
signs prior to the age of 30 because
again this is all this is typically
caused by a poor choice of lifestyle
when it comes to inactivity obesity and
poor diet so even though they may not be
diagnosed with diabetes until sometime
in their 30s or 40s there are plenty of
warning signs leading up to that
diagnosis and so here are some of the
symptoms that may lead a person to
becoming diagnosed as having diabetes
you know some of these are pretty
straightforward but I do want to kind of
translate what some of the other ones
are persons with diabetes so may one of
the main symptoms is that a frequent
thirst this is called polydipsia
polyphagia is an excess hunger and keep
in mind if your cells aren't getting
glucose they're gonna send out a signal
to eat more and that kind of Disick's
aspirates the the problem of having too
much glucose the person feels hungry so
they eat more
another main symptom of diabetes is
polyuria which is frequent urination
because as glucose builds up and builds
up in the blood the kidneys remove the
extra build-up through you and it's just
urinated out of the body and then
glycosuria is excess sugar in the urine
as I just said the kidneys will remove
extra amounts of
and that glucose is urinated out and
therefore a person can test their urine
for blood for sugar in their urine so I
want to show this graph that has two
important pieces of information on it
the yellow line shows the percentage of
Americans who've been diagnosed with
diabetes and on the far right is the
year 2014 and you can see that if we
follow the yellow line which is the
percentage of Americans with diabetes
it's about seven percent of our of our
population the blue line is also going
up over the past thirty forty years and
it shows the number of millions of
people who are diabetics and in 2014
that's about 22 million people now both
lines show that diabetes in the United
States is increasing at a dramatic rate
which is very troubling
so some of the long-term consequences of
diabetes number one is heart disease
like the information here says diabetes
dramatically increases the risk of
cardiovascular problems including
coronary artery disease with chest pain
heart attack stroke the narrowing of
arteries and high blood pressure you
know nerve damage is another long-term
consequence excess sugar can injure the
walls of the tiny blood vessels that
nourish your nerves poorly controlled
blood sugar can eventually cause you to
lose all sense of feeling in the limbs
that are affected blindness blindness is
another long-term consequence diabetes
can damage the blood vessels of the
retina potentially leading to diabetes
potential even to blindness diabetes
also increases the risk of other serious
conditions such as cataracts and
glaucoma you can see a cataract in the
person's eye in this picture here kidney
failure is another long-term consequence
the kidneys contain millions of tiny
blood vessel clusters that will filter
waste from your blood severe damage can
lead to kidney failure or irreversible
end-stage kidney disease which often
requires dialysis or even a kidney
transplant foot sores nerve damage in
the feet poor blood flow to the feet
increases the risk of various foot
complications left untreated cuts and
blisters can become serious infections
which may heal poorly and in many cases
actually have to lead to amputation of
of limbs so there you go I wanted to
leave this up here for a few moments
just a side-by-side comparison of type 1
type 2 diabetes keep in mind both type
of types of diabetes are due to an extra
amount of blood glucose blood sugar in
the bloodstream and the person's
inability to control that glucose level
naturally so I hope you found this
helpful please place your thoughts in
the
it's below